hey everyone Avengers for maybe one step
closer to revealing its title to us with
a cryptic Instagram post from the
directors that was quickly deleted now
what does that post mean and what are
the latest updates on Avengers for words
title and this first look that needs to
happen it's a trailer Feige come on
we're not that far out we'll get to a
vengeance war but first welcome to new
rockstars news 13 I've been to all the
big stores in this week so we're also
gonna talk about the sequel to Doctor
Strange we're gonna talk about
spider-man far from home we're going to
talk about another spider-man Easter egg
that was spotted and stuff I'm Eric
Bostrom it's a stapler same bathroom oh
[Music]
wow that was actually not bad yeah okay
let's get started with our top story the
Avengers for a title as of this
broadcast we still have yet to receive
any teaser title announcement for the
movie which is set premiere April 2019
but but the directors have recently
begun to hint at some possible clues for
it the latest hint was opposed on the
Russo brothers Instagram of an art
exhibit
that's called aftermath of obliteration
of eternity it shows the entrance to the
infinity mirrored room and the caption
for the photo read a4 title reveal dot
before the whole post was quickly taken
down now just explain the context here
aftermath of obliteration of eternity is
an art exhibit an installation created
by Japanese artist Yayoi Kusama
it's currently on display in Houston was
a brief description of the experience
viewers are invited to step into the
room and stand on a central platform
over time a delicate shimmering Mirage
unfolds as an array of lights ignites
and is mirrored on every surface of the
all-encompassing environment in less
than a minute however all light
disappears and the cycle starts anew
that's pretty cool I want to go to there
now you can see how Thea matically this
may have reminded the Russo brothers of
the end of infinity war and perhaps the
concepts are dealing with with Avengers
4 and photo of the sign reading and
aftermath of obliteration of eternity
was probably just a joke from there one
of you but the description from the
artists win read closely kind of sets
off some more alert here's what she said
life is what I always try to understand
its depth and its mystique if rise and
fall yeah I understand the greatness
brought by this mystique as well as that
is eternal and keeps appearing and
disappearing yet we keep flashing and
disappearing and again blossoming out in
this eternity you guys eternity
certainly sounds like a trigger word for
me because the Russo brothers have
talked on a podcast about various a for
title options like there's infinity
crusade Avengers endgame Avengers fallen
Nero's Avengers Oh into the darkness I
don't know they also said that Avengers
forever forever was very close in their
words now in other word for forever is
eternity okay Oh Eternity and is
actually a character in the Marvel
comics he's a cosmic entity that shows
up in the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
and he's essentially the living
embodiment of the universe itself yeah I
know it sounds about as trippy as going
into that a mirror room right
he joins Adam warlock in appealing to
the Living Tribunal to intervene stop
Thanos they end up failing doesn't work
out but eternity has been teased in the
MCU before in guardians the galaxy vol 2
Peter Quill's perception of the universe
remember was expanded by ego and his
high school blacking story he says I see
eternity and I don't know I heard that
it's an uppercase e
eternity but what do you guys think do
you think eternity could at least show
up in Avengers or could he be the one
behind the trippy twist had been rumored
and how likely is it that Stan Lee will
play eternity yes I think that I think
that do you remember the cosmic entity
of the Living Tribunal on display in
Doctor Strange the walking stick yeah
like that was essentially like it felt
like they were like we don't know how to
do it so look at a stick and it whips
there's a lot Martina's but yeah it kind
of was like to me like they just it just
feels like they've never had an answer
for that right like you're another
things like how are they gonna do
Galactus right like that's what I always
been like this obvious thing of like
what is it gonna be a big dude like a
real scooter in downtown New York and
then he eats the planet like yes a
little instead of color like the
Galactus boot you know like it just
feels like there's a certain level
entity I mean ego even right they could
only do like a little nod to ego being a
planet well they had to do a lot of work
to justify his whole existence like Kurt
Russell to spend ten minutes of the
movie explaining his back Museum on his
own face to explain what he is yeah so
my biggest argument against that
happening is that I think that they have
so much introduced already with Thanos
and and in whatever everything happened
in this movie that just came out that we
just kind of leave it to our heroes now
like our heroes were barely in that
movie you know what I mean let our
heroes solve the problem maybe they can
discover things that they too have been
previously known but to bring in some
sort of you know deus ex machina figure
that can just be like well what if I
unsnap you know like that just kind of
undoes the whole thing yeah you could
just simply unsnap why not do that and
leave the heroes to just sit on the
bench for the story yeah I don't think
it when they said eternity with the eyes
like that was the class all I ever
needed it was like yeah he can just
perceive that this is bigger than he is
that's about as far as you can go cuz
after that because sometimes people can
talk to eternity like it's a person and
he has clothes on and it's like super
it's cool in a comic because you can
kind of just disconnect a little bit but
when there's something in my brain that
says I don't know how you could possibly
do that in a movie that wouldn't like
let it like we would just lose it we
wouldn't be like okay now they've was it
jump the shark so what's called like
were they they kind of like they go
legal little too far with the
storytelling
I also saw in that description I saw a
mystique pop up like three times and
someone said flashed you can get a
flashpoint there's also that and there
and the x-men would that possibly happen
I don't know yeah I mean I definitely
stand by it they were joking like its
patrol yeah they love to troll but like
wouldn't it be the ultimate troll if
like the title reveal is avengers
eternity and then there's like it was
there right in front of you the whole
I'm feeling lately it's gonna keep
changing every week but right now I'm
feeling in legacy legacy was out there a
little bit as a word that was kind of
coming around a lot and it kind of often
eyes like what's left behind after we're
gone but then not only because of you
know I'll have the
gone right now but also you know is this
the last time we're gonna see maybe Tony
Stark or this a lot of time we see Kevin
wrecking the legacy care yeah what is
their legacy gonna be after they leave
or like a new Iron Man yeah and then a
legacy also like it you know if you're
if your parents one of the same
universities you right you adopting
their mantle in a way of going there to
you are considered a legacy yeah you
could do Avengers leftovers because
there'll everyone's leftover you could
do Avengers graveyard smash and you
could have the font in on gravestones
because everyone's half the universe
yeah there's a couple options yeah I
will say just one last like tinfoil hat
push for for eternity being the possible
answer of what the title will be I never
would have thought a year ago that
Feige and the Marvel team would be
willing to actually have the nose go
through with the snap that's something
that will felt like it because comics
thing I never would have thought that
ego the Living Planet could appear in a
movie or that Dormammu could appear in a
movie I feel like they're gradually like
getting mass autism on board with making
some of these like because comics type
moves in movies and I don't think it's
too out of the realm of possibility to
show some form of eternity especially I
know this is the craziest idea but
especially if it's just Stan Lee if they
can get Stan Lee just to play this part
I feel like audiences would be like wait
what you know I'll say that it doesn't
just because I'm not feeling knowing
that it's gonna be a title doesn't mean
that like some version of Eternity
couldn't appear III it just reminds me a
lot of like when you put the the name of
like the new shiny character in it it's
you know Avengers rise of the Silver
Surfer something like that that feel
were like take a little cheesy
age of Ultron it's not a great I didn't
like it scary the title was a very short
age it's cool it's a cool I will say
it's a cool it's a cool theory to do if
Stanley was eternity and that's this is
how in eternity cuz it's so vast it just
makes itself look like Stanley an
unassuming old man that kind of is
everywhere but everyone's like not
paying attention like it's a that's a
fun idea for a character I
yeah it's gonna have to require like I
honestly 100% agree I would prefer this
needs to be the hero's journey you know
and we need to see the original six
Avengers plus the new friends that
they've gained being the once actually
solved this crisis and it would feel
really cheap if it was just some kind of
day six not gonna figure but something
has to be behind the trippy cosmic stuff
that will probably be happening and
Avengers for like I don't know if it
will be time travel exactly but there's
gonna have to be some kind of like
cosmic answer to how they defeat Thanos
because otherwise why couldn't they do
it war there's plenty and if they just
come up with it on their own mmm like
they're gonna need some kind of outside
assistance
what about quantum realms so if you go
small enough you can they perceive with
the quantum realm as whatever gooey mess
of things that is happening and that's
whatever sub sub sub sub atomic if you
go the other way and what if they
perceived it from the outside as like
them trying to get a different
perspective so it looks like a person I
don't know it give me going like so
macro yeah like like weird like the
whole universe is like an insignificant
yeah but he'd go small yeah go big yeah
I think that there's like you'd run into
that problem of the their body wouldn't
be able to do it yeah at a certain point
when he took his helmet off in the
quantum realm and he was breathing fine
and like she's been alive for 16 oxygen
it's super confusing probably the one
solution for what could be their own
self discovered technological way to
defeating them because we did learn time
vortexes exist part of it in a throwaway
line throw out there I'm not saying that
we won't see a new character that is
vital to their solution because in the
end there's so many characters that that
are in the comic storyline very relevant
right around here that aren't playing a
role yet I kind of see that
yeah and that mirror room in the art
exhibit looks like eternity that's what
I'm saying yeah as any story thing looks
like eternity so that must mean it
you turn to be confirmed yep that's
gonna be no I've been shaking their head
editor's give me a thumbs down we spit
mad okay well let's move on to this
week's trivia question who's staying on
the subject of cosmic entities okay so
here we go in the MCU one cosmic entity
has appeared we were talking about him
the celestial ego the Living Planet and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 now ego
was actually a property that was owned
by Fox but Fox allowed Marvel to use him
in exchange for the right to
fundamentally change a Marvel character
in an upcoming Fox movie who was that
character alright all of our answers are
here in the bucket here and later in the
show reveal the answer to the trivia
question the closest as decided by our
judges will do our sign-off get nice at
the end of the video meanwhile the loser
will partake in our trivia punishment be
a new inductee to the gif of shame and
if you get it wrong at home you gotta
give yourself a little poking the bupkis
yeah oh yeah Santa always knows okay
let's move on to an update here from
this week a Doctor Strange sequel is
underway with reports of Benedict
Cumberbatch reprising the role and
hoping to begin shooting in spring of
2019 now it was said he's being paid 7.5
million pounds or roughly nine point six
million u.s. dollars now this is a first
update we've heard about Doctor Strange
- moving forward since Marvel has been
pretty hush-hush about phase four when
the first Doctor Strange movie came out
director scott derrickson said nightmare
would be his choice to be the villain to
explore for the sequel and nightmare of
course as I'm sure you all know is the
ruler of the dream dimension he draws
his power from like the psychic energy
of people who are sleeping and dreaming
he's kind of like nightmare embodied the
way
is the universe embodied so it sounds
like some real creepy trippy stuff is in
store for the second movie if they
continue to go in that direction what do
you guys think you excited for this hey
you want inception but you want it in
the MCU there you go that's your pitch
for it also it's cool like the idea I
like one of my favorite um Justice
League cartoon episodes was when they
dealt with whatever the version of
Nightmare is for them it's I think it's
dr. destiny makes no sense but he didn't
invade people's dreams with psychic
energy and whatnot and it's the league
trying to stay awake as long as they can
Batman stirs sitting in his car he
breaks open the windshield so that the
wind can keep hitting him in the face
he gets coffee he's like trying Freddy
Krueger yeah which is something that you
can get a horror element from that as
well and also if you get into dream just
kind of like me or dimension where it's
like anything can happen it's also
dreams
it's like anything well the beginning of
dreams like well there have been dreamed
in the MCU actually I think yeah Tony
Stark's dream right but the idea of like
dreams being a something you can enter
yeah that's that's super fun especially
if it's a different take than the way
inception did it but like they set up a
sequel at the end of Doctor Strange
already with Baron maybe they team up
one more time in the third movie he's
got take him down unless they team up
one last time and he sacrifices himself
that's Loki over 19 movies so this is
just some more evidence to that people
who got snapped away they're coming back
in some way right like you can't go on
forever because we know according to
galaxies it could be set between the
events like it didn't matter enough to
make it then now let's go back let's see
this shooting spring 2019 so probably
came out 2021 they're like this movie
actually was set three and a half years
ago so yeah yeah that timeline stuff
they can just do whatever do that math
the nineties yeah yeah all nighter man
sixty years old in college they're just
like really messing this thing up
hello fellows speaking of Spidey another
update from this past week so far from
home has cast Remy he in an unknown role
he's an Australian actor featured
recently in the movie crazy rich Asians
you should definitely check out it's
awesome he makes another interesting
mystery cast announcement for far from
home which as I pointed out in the video
earlier this week seems to be loading up
on villains and what appears to be a
possible move toward the sinister six
did they say that he is a villain they
did not sound good he looks like I mean
with the eyebrows it looks like a
Modesto right but did they already
establish that character in Martin Starr
was it Martin Starr Wow then they retcon
that it was in he was no no sorry I
forgot that he has a different role he's
an Incredible Hulk
Martin Starr is and then in the in the
novelization of that that was like yeah
that's Amadeus Cho Cho is like it
doesn't make any sense yeah it is a
super bad but I mean you could do that
you could go that angle but also there's
so many rogues you could pick from he
usually though is it depends on who's
writing but they've kind of established
he's a teenager and he looks a little
bit older a little too handsome to be a
kid I think it's since we did young
Spidey we could easily do college age
Cho like yeah with the mystery part
because it seems like we've identified
four possible villains so far in the MCU
we got into the spider-man
we got vulture you know Michael Keaton's
coming back Michael mando is probably
gonna come back as scorpion otherwise
why put him in that post afraid of see
hmm
and they've announced Jake Gyllenhaal
although Jake hasn't really said
anything about it there have been
several reports saying he's gonna be
playing Mysterio and they cast a new
mana card to be playing a character
named Dmitri which like the only Dimitri
in the spider-man universe is chameleon
and then so that kind of leaves two and
then there's that one thing that we
pointed out where there's like this big
wave attack on onset video which people
like most be Hydra man and doesn't just
something good splash you know big
splash ooh I have four possible villains
if you're not going for the sinister six
right like they're trying to get the
sinister six somewhere in these movies
they haven't completely given up hope on
it the only reason they stopped is
because they formed this deal with
Marvel and Feige to have like
rebooted version that would appear in
civil war and potentially have his own
movie and partnership with Marvel and
they saw much more financial opportunity
to do it that way especially after the
amazing spider-man 2 kind of didn't
underperform yeah so yeah I think I
wouldn't be surprised and I also have
like kind of a weird conspiracy theory
that far from home well is not the real
title I think it's crazy that they
announced it that way this accident all
like tablet showing by Tom Hollands
showing like Spider Man far from home
and in fact he's like yeah that's it I
wouldn't be surprised if that's not the
actual title if their last second change
to spider-man center stage - or 6 or
something Keaton he kinda had it seems
like I kind of like how it rhymes like
homecoming far from home you know but I
think like hmm I far from home - sounds
a little generic a little bit but I
agree right I'm actually I would you
should tweet at us like your predictions
for who you think that is cuz I'd
actually be a fun conversation to have
with people cuz like I was looking at
him and also like they have a lower tier
here are villains as well like overdrive
is someone who's out there who's really
fun to play with her boomerang and they
play a lot with shocker who is out there
doing something and the rest of the
sinister six overdrive can just like
touch a car and then turn it into a
sports car it makes it zero sense but
it's really fun and like they've even
tried to explain it it's like we're not
a hundred percent sure but it happens
and boomerangs are really popular one as
well who gets a lot of comedy and it
would be fun to see like a villain who's
actually like a comedic role and have
like see them have fun yeah well yeah
let us know for sure in the comments and
let's move on to another spider-man
related update there was actually a
spider-man infinity war Easter egg that
was spotted in Disneyland and so the
park added a Daily Bugle newspaper stand
with the front page showing Evan Eamon
shape over New York and in the headline
oh no they didn't Iron Man spider-man
scene fighting the alien foes and if you
look at the top margin you could see
other headlines that read what kind of
joins global stage how the nations
reacted princess Sharia coachella fierce
royal fashion scene and vibranium
miracle metal what the future may bring
oh now these of course are references to
Black Panther at the end of that movie
it ended with what kind of revealing
itself to the United Nations remember
there's that joke with Cherie back to
chala for Coachella tickets that you're
going to take me to Coachella
it's also interesting that this is the
headline like presumably Ironman
inspired me in fighting the Black Order
being front page news would mean this
issue was from like the
right before yeah it's gotta be like a
moment earlier and then like the person
who would have stopped and changed it is
gone yeah like right the new headlines
yeah this is like the most maybe all the
Daily Bugle staff was snapped away and
that's why they don't have a new one but
also the Civil War happened two years
before infinity war right in the
timeline of the MCU yes and then black
panther happened a week after Civil War
so a lot of those stories are from -
there's a two-year gap between the first
ones the anniversary of one Wakanda join
the global stage maybe they didn't go to
the United Nations until significantly
after maybe that was a baby Spiderman
now buy tickets for us to go to
Disneyland for you we just want to go in
California Adventure hey that's where
the Marvel I'm going one day and I'll
let you know oh really
birthday price is how we found out and
then one more update actually speaking
of Black Panther Disney is reportedly
pushing for a Best Picture nomination
for Black Panther despite the Academy's
recent announcement of a new popular
film category that many believes could
have been designed to cater to Black
Panthers specifically now according to
one Oscar consultant which is a job I
did not know existed the chief executive
of the Oscars would crawl in a hole and
that person's words if black panther got
snubbed for Best Picture and ended up
just in the popular film category and
said a veteran Oscar campaigner just
again a job I did not know existed you
may want to remind voters that this
wasn't or know you want to remind voters
that this wasn't just a movie it was a
phenomenon the depth of that impact what
it meant to people what it stood for if
Academy members didn't get it then they
need to understand it now do you guys
agree do you think that Black Panther
should be promoted on that level of
promoted sure right selected I feel
differently that argument you just gave
at the end there
like a great argument for the popular
film category in general right like
that's recognizing something for being a
moment and not necessarily the best film
well there are plenty of movies though
that somehow get in that category for
Best Picture and you're like what are
you doing also in crash 1 ivory watched
crash that thing is it's engineered only
to get in that category which is it that
it shouldn't have been it shouldn't even
be in popular films not a lot of people
saw it but they got a series after
anyways digressing if because of the
cultural importance of this movie I feel
like it has just as much of a right to
be there as the rest of the movies and
like I guess I'm a Pierce about like
what we're rewarding they're like I'm
very politically active I'm very
sensitive to like representation all
these things and I feel like you know
the success of those things mean the
movies get made and people go see them
and the movies get advertised to decide
that a movie has like because it's doing
that is also of a certain quality is to
move it to a different scale that it
wasn't playing on initially it reminds
me of this thing that came out recently
of Justin Lin's first film was an
all-asian cast it's where John Cho was
discovered and a couple of other
prominent Asian actors and a guy stood
up at the Sundance screening and he was
like you know movies fine or whatever
but your characters are amoral how dare
you do that to the asian-american
community and just by chance Roger Ebert
happened to be in the audience too and
he stood up and he screamed at the guy
and he was like how dare you how dare
you tell them that Asian Americans have
to be presented in some way because it
matters so much the most the best thing
we can do is let them be whatever they
want to be so to me it's like yeah sure
it's a very you know significant film
let it be the film that it is that
doesn't also mean that we need to move
it over to a scale of judgement of like
did it that means it had the best
directing and the best script and the
best acting like that's really what Best
Picture is trying to say right it's all
the elements of the film these were the
best representations on average as a
whole it's just a different conversation
I would be saying it a little
differently if the movie was honestly
better
than every film that came out last year
period mm-hmm it wasn't that it was up
there for me there were ways that last
year okay that's why I get what you're
saying I got confused for a second um
that's fair but also it's kind of like
idealistic a little bit because also the
way that you guys should do deep dives
into how Oscars how things actually at
nominated because it's all a game of
money it's about there's only a select
number of people who actually get to
choose what gets nominated and then even
smaller what actually wins like that and
people are catered to with like free
things and it's it's not as perfect as
it should be and you do have good points
where it's like the this movie probably
isn't on the same level as a lot of
movies that should be up in Best Picture
at the same time it has the notoriety
that a lot of the movies that should
have Best Picture don't have right yeah
who doesn't know what Black Panthers who
hasn't seen Black Panther right but then
it's like phantom thread last year
people were like I haven't even seen
that but the people that saw it were
like oh holy crap that is a very good
movie so even though the money is
playing a role I mean how much more
money is there than the promotion of
Black Panther is this great event
fulfilled yeah this whole idea of the
Oscar campaign it is super political and
it really is the numbers in a money game
yep and the whole system of that was
created by Miramax in the wine states
that it did not happen people like there
was like a community it was very much
like an old man's club who just kind of
like honored what they consider to be
the best one so it wasn't perfect before
they came in but they kind of went in
there and that's why like I believe
Shakespeare in Love beat Saving Private
Ryan that year because we were like well
how did you know what it was but it was
a movie that was kind of engineered to
win Oscars and they changed the game so
that every year after that you could see
these movies that were not necessarily
bad but they were just they were great
but they were clearly like being
calculated in a way of like okay but
we're not gonna aim to make a lot of
money with this movie we are gonna try
to write our studios have football blah
blah but it doesn't I mean this may be
just my opinion but it feels like leave
like Oscars be the Oscars eventful films
give them every other thing right give
this movie a star on the Walk of Fame
right no other movie has that but like
that the impact you know the
the the moon-landing has a star on the
Walk of Fame has a special significance
star because it was like this was such a
big moment in media that even though we
only do actors directors writers
playwrights things like that on the Walk
of Fame they just put and in this moment
in media which is like so special this
movie it to me is special in that way
where we should be honoring in all kinds
of different ways you know throw em on
Mount Rushmore like whatever but to me
specifically the Academy Award for Best
Picture is just artistry at it's like
finest I think there's amazing artistry
give it other awards Best Picture
specifically just means like every
single part of this thing had to be
perfect it's interesting that you say
that idealistically
I in in a perfect world that's what it
should be well I want I want to apply
that to every film in that can and
that's actually how it should be across
the board but then it it just depends it
depends on what happens like last year I
saw a good time and that's never gonna
get that's never like that movie is
never going to be mentioned at all it
was from two directors Robert Pattinson
and it's one of the best performances
I've ever seen it's such a good bottle
like it's caps encapsulate it's so much
of a specific community but it will
never get any recognition and I don't
even know if you can buy it on DVD like
it's and that bums me out but like it
does come back to money so it's like
that we can say as much as we like but
it just depends on how much money gets
behind certain people and what happens
after that so movie to me seems the most
profound with its message and it's theme
tends to be worthy of an Oscar and I
think like even movies that seem like
big action movies I think like a movie
like Black Panther does have a very
profound message that you would not
expect for it to have so in my mind that
even if some of the artistry like you
could maybe argue some of the direction
or some of the pacing or maybe some of
the dialogue seems a little you know
there's all little ways that you can
like poke holes in it but I think at the
end the day like that is one of the 10
probably most profound messages and most
well conveyed themes in a movie that
threw the direction of the camera and
through the acting performances and
through the visual effects and and
pasting sequences in the script that I
saw this year so I wouldn't be bummed if
it got nominated for a Best Picture but
I do hear you saying like maybe let the
Oscars be I agree with you it's just I
don't know
nominated is very different from like
potentially winning to and like it's a
pretty big group that they nominate so
yeah it might actually be worth it I
don't know that I totally agree on you
know a strong theme being the most
important thing even though I always
seek a strong theme because movie can be
real garbage and have a real strong
theme the whole time and they're telling
you about the theme constantly right and
they're telling you in every single way
but really quick that's my fear yeah
crash is a good example but yeah crash
is a great example of that and but but
not only is crashed a great example of
that but then on the other side let's
all remind ourselves we do it every week
anyway the dark night was the best
picture that year in every way mm-hmm
right and there was like just no doubt
about it so that's kind of what I mean
where it's like you know when you talk
about Black Panther are you saying it's
on level with the Dark Knight to me no
it's not but if it had been I'd be like
yes Black Panther deserves to be win
best picture yeah and I like that you
say Black Panther should get its own
star on the Walk of Fame because that's
essentially why we call yourselves new
rockstars right because you don't have
to be a specific person right to be like
a moment something that we consider to
be a star sometimes it's it's a really
the spiral thing that we're all talking
yeah but oh sorry before we move on but
like what you mentioned about like being
a cultural movement I think that's why
for me and I think that probably
reflects with the audience is that
that's why the MCU probably means so
much to me bless you it's just it's
because it's something that's never been
done before and maybe why I forgive a
lot of things that happened in it where
it's like because it feels like
something special and I'm excited to see
how it wraps up and if it got an Oscar
nom I wouldn't be upset are you guys
ready okay he's good all right Sam mr.
Alberta has wants to know why
superheroes play sports it's not fair
it's lightning they know that too strong
they go too fast I'll commence winds
it's a sport i Superman played football
in high school and it was amazing no he
plays one game he played one game and
then his Papa said you could help maybe
kill some of you trip but that was my
favorite moment every depiction of that
football game is just like that's what I
would be like Mike and Morris Chestnut
it's a great movie the six man what a
bad person he's a ghost that's like Mike
better be nominee for Oscars for popular
film and art direction in 29 Bow Wow
I'll lose my mind Phillip at Future past
13 wants to know who should Mark Hamill
play in the Lightning because I really
like Mark Hamill but his age immediately
like removed him from like the
characters I'd more excited about like
he can only play characters that I'm not
excited about you could play eternity
yeah I guess I'm still on the fence
about the cosmic entities or whatever
yeah yeah JJ Jameson sorry I didn't mean
to be flippant about it it's more that
when I wouldn't a now said I was like oh
cool wait what are they gonna do with
them that's almost why that question
well that would that would have been
honestly like a kind of good fit for him
because he's so over the top too but at
but it I hate that he's aging - that
makes me sad it's upsetting this also
Jay jonah Jameson come on guys that's
good I want to hear him screaming over
Joker voice of saucer yeah okay defer to
say and then those questions sure not to
decide what my question will be to begin
with because I'm trying to be fair
lightning you know
lightning lightning good question you've
already been asked some of these
actually so I like them so I'm just
gonna go uh well with the books and
library oh my god
at a Sunday duck okay it's good why do
you reference Beauty and the Beast so
much okay the questions like Mike yeah
that you're the two films you've seen
he's paid money for which new rock stars
video has required the highest number of
takes for you and why okay I don't I
haven't tracked I I calculate everything
and tabulate everything not this though
yeah your girlfriend loves this is all
while you're wrong that I break down
that we did fun fact I was recording
like three in the morning and I got it
would it took me like an hour and a half
to record it cuz we would all in one
take I realized I was not I did not hit
record through it so I was a five in the
morning doing but I think the first
video that one of the first videos yeah
you can actually watch it was like a
Wonder Woman trailer breakdown or
something and I can you cannot yeah but
you also were she was doing that thing
was oscillating between like cracking up
and being so mad like Anakin all the mad
moments but do you want me to do I was I
wrote a dumb joke in the outline and I
was like Trenton wasn't gonna choke I
was just saying like Ocean Spray there's
a shot of it was Justice League maybe I
don't know there's a shot of Aquaman
getting hit by the wave and I kept
saying ocean sprayed I kept thinking to
the cranapple put together five and put
in the video and the viewers at the time
we're not ready to find me a charming
gotta butter them up first three
questions this week and keep them coming
every week just tweet us at new rock
stories and look out for our lightning
round tweeting you could be featured in
the show but now comes the time for a
15-second shout outs for each of us
that's 50 seconds a shout out plug we
ramble about anything we want Sam why
don't you start anything anything okay
well I started a new game of Thrones
podcast called hard to say goodbye if
you want to watch it and listen
dang it it's a bits and audio podcast go
listen to it you go touch it you
it's on my Twitter you can click on it
we talked about it with Trisha
Hershberger if you're familiar with her
it's a fun little show hope you enjoy it
thank you
goodbye I'm trying to I'm trying to
remember because I was so excited to
share what it was it was something that
I just like discovered on Netflix or
something but man I'm forgetting I was
like this is perfect for my 15th because
I turn into a big night i man I think
I'll just say the the fact that like
Batman Begins and Dark Knight just came
to Netflix so they're like just like
it's a perfect time to just very easily
go and rewatch those I have like a more
interesting announcement about that but
I can't tell you guys yet oh oh bring it
up later and a third one for my 15
seconds maybe some of you follow me on
instagram or twitter saw like this
cryptic announcement with our Infinity
Gauntlet and I'm doing a live Marvel
parody show I don't have like permanence
of what it's called but it is gonna be
September 29th because guys like I love
doing new rocks of stuff but really my
real patch and the reason I'm in LA is I
do a bunch of live comedy and maybe I
don't really seem that funny always on
new rock stars it's kind of like this is
an informational thing so if I do Eric
is very funny
thank you hey behind us know I sound
like a substitute teacher who planned a
couple jokes before today's lesson and I
think yeah of the way you perceive me
here but like yeah I do a bunch of like
improv and sketch in LA and I what I'm
here to do so yeah I'm putting together
a pair to show that's kind of like what
we talked about here I'm making it kind
of just for you guys so if you live in
the LA area
follow me Eddie gave us - just keep your
eye out for some of these updates cuz
I'm really excited about the show I
think it's gonna be a show that you find
very funny but also like a very
interesting story that I'm that I'm
putting together with it with the team
I'm very excited about so look out for
more details cool yeah cool
well let us finally return to the trivia
question that we asked earlier and just
as a reminder our
the punishment that needs like a sound
effect to it Bouchet it should be like
the those singers from where in the
world would comment its comfort in Diego
get both stream okay now just remind you
guys what this is the wrong stance will
have to draw tasks from gesture of the
gift of shame container Kurt Russell
could be one of them and to perform that
task repeatedly while the winner reads a
goodbyes and then the other one will
chant shame it you do a bunch of weird
crap in there and your stupidity will be
turned into an animated gif yeah let's
um real quick on social media this is a
no turtles for media person to don't put
the words gif of shame on top of the
gift because I want to see people in the
audience use this gif in like everyday
conversation to embarrass us without
context you can decide the context
that's part of the fun of it
okay so don t guys are the question it
was who did like Fox walk to marvel
so that Marvel could use ego the Living
Planet so what character was changed in
a fox movie at permission of Marvel so
that that could happen our answers Oh
from fimo negasonic teenage warhead
which is also what Sam said and then
Eric said cobbler
I love it it's amazing okay so my shame
a Falcon landed on your head and you're
trying to shoo it away without
threatening it no I get the same chain
well everyone thanks so much for
watching this week's episode of new
rockstars news I want to thank our hosts
we got Sam basher down at the end with
the sweaty armpit and you find him and
his sweat Sam basher in most places that
matter Erik Voss at you a boss it's in
the name right and me I'm Phil Molina at
fimo this is plenty of content America
you can tell a whole story with that
amount so go ahead and comment down
below about all the things we talked
about earlier we had a lot of different
discussion points and I think they were
very contentious and we got on a lot of
fights that we had to cut out but we
want to hear your opinions on them I
also tweet at us at new rock stars and
let us know what you want to talk about
in the next one of these or we want us
to cover soon hey if you got real good
ideas that aren't infinity war well do
them and like this video shared around
maybe watch it with your friends that
are into it and paint a picture and
subscribe to this channel new rock stars
because we do all kinds of stuff and we
got really interesting stuff coming soon
but in general we will see you as a
collective next week Eric we'll see you
sooner than that probably what's the
Falcons name told you he's funny
improv
feathers was brainstorm for an
eight-hour period we cut it out yeah
doctor feathers oh yeah you brought out
food you might yeah it's tested some
microphones in the way I was doing all
this good stuff